[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
hallo und guten abend ihnen allen dass
asaf stahlwerk im südosten der ukraine
muss die dort seit wochen
eingeschlossenen menschen die hölle auf
erden sein es ist auch zu einem symbol
geworden die letzte bastion ukrainischer
kämpfer in der von russland fast
komplett eroberten und fast komplett
zerstörten stadt mariupol
jetzt haben russische einheiten mit
einer großoffensive begonnen die nicht
nur dem stahlwerk gilt sie soll den
besatzern auch eine landverbindung zur
krim sichern york bill hat mehr
raketen auf die letzte bastion des
ukrainischen widerstands in mariupol das
off stahlwerk die erstürmung durch die
russische armee soll begonnen haben noch
immer befinden sich im inneren wohl auch
zivilisten
es war kurz nach zwei in der nacht
plötzlich eine entsetzliche explosion es
gab ein dutzend verletzte gebrochene
beine arme und dann diese beiden mädchen
was müssen sie gelitten haben sie
wollten doch nur weg von hier die
ganze nacht über sei das oft stahlwerk
bombardiert worden derzeit läuft ein
groß angelegter angriff auf den
industriekomplex des konzerns aus stahl
mit unterstützung von bodentruppen
panzern und schiffen vom wasser aus wir
werden alles tun um diesen angriff
abzuwehren
wie es im rest der belagerten stadt
aussieht zeigen diese aufnahmen über
100.000 zivilisten harren derzeit
offenbar noch in mario pohl aus eine von
ihnen ist tatjana bussler nova
du wachst morgens auf und weinst du
weinst am abend ich weiß nicht wo ich
hingehen soll und damit bin ich nicht
alleine alles ist zerstört alles ist
kaputt wo sollen wir hin gehen und
während sie dort inmitten von trümmern
sitzt und erzählt schlägt ganz in ihrer
nähe wieder eine rakete
sie sind der hölle von mario pohl
entkommen haben es aus dem us oft
stahlwerk heraus geschafft endlich mit
bussen kommen sie heute in sapporo an
ihr versteht nicht wie schrecklich es
ist wenn du in einem nassen kalten
keller sitzt und es rüttelt und wackelt
überall als wir endlich auf die straße
raus gehen konnten sah ich die sonne zum
zweiten mal in zwei monaten
es ist tag 69 des krieges und die
menschen wollen nur noch weg egal wie
die sonne zum zweiten mal in zwei
monaten das ist die lage in der kiew
heute einen besucher aus deutschland
empfängt der damit zu hause schlagzeilen
macht und eine ziemliche diskussion
ausgelöst hat deutschland dürfte das
einzige land sein aus dem der
oppositionschef die ukraine im krieg
noch vor dem regierungschef besucht
jetzt kann man sagen das ist egal wer
wann kommt man kann auch sagen das ist
ein politikum ich habe gleich fragen an
friedrich merz aber erst mathis feldhoff
über einen oppositionsführer auf der
suche nach eigenen eindrücken vor ort
und auf der suche nach seiner rolle im
krieg
wenn der deutsche oppositionsführer bei
einer reise nicht nur den kiefer
bürgermeister vitali klitschko und sein
bruder trifft sondern hinter
verschlossenen türen auch den
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
spricht das für zwei lesarten die
deutsche unterstützung wird geschätzt
und deutsche politiker werden im prinzip
gern empfangen irgendwie sowieso
andererseits
besucher zu haben freunde
so sehr ist sehr wichtig dass es eine
symbolische besuch wir schützen und
verteidigen ja auch unsere demokratie
unsere freiheit so wie wir leben auch in
deutschland am vormittag war märz
zunächst in die kabine
vor ort von kiew hier so erzählt es ihm
der bürgermeister waren die kämpfer am
heftigsten hier wurde der russische
vormarsch auf die hauptstadt gestartet
friedrich merz ist sichtlich ergriffen
nach einem blick in eines der zerstörten
häuser
das ist so furchtbar sagt der cdu
vorsitzende mehr zu sich selbst nichts
ist mehr in ihre bienen die von 69 tagen
vor dem kriegsbeginn
ich bin voller trauer über die
zahlreichen opfer die es hier gegeben
hat aber auch gleichzeitig voller
bewunderung über das was die armee was
die ukrainischen soldatinnen und
soldaten hier geleistet haben märz folgt
bei seiner reise einer einfachen
strategie er treibt die bundesregierung
schon bei den waffenlieferungen so
findet er habe das funktioniert heute
sichert in berlin durch das die
koalition jetzt auch bereits so schwere
panzer und pizzen zu liefern für märz
ist das eine gratwanderung einerseits
oppositionsführer andererseits
unterstützer der regierung in
kriegszeiten noch vor ein paar tagen
voller attacke auf den abwesenden
kanzler der bundeskanzler hat über
wochen die diskussion über die frage ob
der ukraine der nun waffen geliefert
werden sollten oder nicht hingehalten
offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortete olaf scholz
versucht den spieß umzudrehen merz reise
sein wahrheit eine mission im auftrag
der regierung so die subtile botschaft
des kanzlers erstens hat er mich aber
seinen wunsch informiert und ich habe da
keine anwendung und sie billiger oben
liege das und zweitens ist es so dass
wir natürlich auch hinterher über das
was er mir mitzuteilen hat sprechen
werden es ist eine wunde in der
koalition dass die reisetätigkeit der
regierung so gehandicapt ist dem
vizekanzler ist seine unzufriedenheit
förmlich anzumerken
wäre ich in der opposition ist ja auch
in die ukraine gereist dass wir als so
jedoch nicht da sind das hat ja die
bundeskanzlerin führt liegt im kern auch
daran dass der bundespräsident
ausgeladen wurde und
da wird es aber auch eine lösung geben
wie rinder dauern miteinander ein
machtkampf zwischen ihm und dem kanzler
fast generis kündigt merz heute an er
wolle jetzt auch helfen die gründe für
scholz reise und lust nach kiew
auszuräumen
friedrich merz cdu chef und
oppositionsführer im deutschen bundestag
ist jetzt bei uns in der sendung aus
kiew guten abend herr merz
was hat sie denn persönlich am meisten
mitgenommen an diesem tag heute in kiew
das war eindeutig der besuch im
stadtteil ihre pin also in dem stadtteil
der wie butter auch massiv zerstört
worden ist kirchen kulturzentren
kindergärten krankenhäuser private
wohnung völlig sinnlose zerstörung und
dann die menschen getroffen die in
diesen häusern gewohnt haben den
bürgermeister getroffen der dort
gleichzeitig auch der militärkommandant
war als der russische angriff auf die
stadt kiew begonnen hat also das muss
man mal aus der nähe gesehen haben um
den eindruck wirklich zu bekommen wie
schrecklich dieser krieg ist und wie
völlig sinnlos diese zerstörungen sind
die hier auch tatsächlich angerichtet
worden sind das muss man mal aus der
nähe gesehen haben haben sie gerade
gesagt ist das ein wink mit dem
zaunpfahl auch an den bundeskanzler
also das muss er selber entscheiden ich
kann ihm nur empfehlen das zu tun auch
die gespräche dann hier zu führen ich
habe heute den staatspräsidenten
getroffen den ministerpräsidenten
getroffen den parlamentspräsidenten
getroffen die oppositionsführer
getroffen und dann zum schluss noch
vladimir klitschko als bürgermeister der
stadt kiel diese gespräche können sie
nicht am telefon machen die können sie
auch nicht mit videokonferenzen machen
sie müssen diese gespräche persönlich
führen und das ist schon eindrucksvoll
was dieses land auch was die politische
führung dieses landes hier leistet und
ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen diese
gespräche zu führen ich bin jedenfalls
zutiefst dankbar dass ich heute diesen
tag hier verbringen konnte jetzt ist es
aber herr merz so dass der bundeskanzler
ja tatsächlich
oft ständig regelmäßig und lange mit
präsident zielinski eben telefoniert was
können sie denn dem bundeskanzler jetzt
noch über bringen was er nicht ohnehin
schon weiß
sie was ich würde ganz gerne das was ich
ihm zu sagen habe auch aus meinen
persönlichen gesprächen die ihr
persönlich auch übermitteln und das
nicht über die nachrichten tun aber ich
kann durchaus einiges sagen auch zu den
zukünftigen beziehungen mit der ukraine
zu dem was wir tun könnten auch jenseits
der waffenlieferungen da geht es ja auch
um die fragen des wiederaufbaus da geht
es um die fragen auch der nato der der
europäischen union und der
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
da geht es um die frage auch der
garantie möchte für die zukunft also da
gibt es einige politische fragen ging
aber die würde ich gerne mit ihm
persönlich klären nicht über die medien
und sie meinen das ist etwas was
präsident zielinski nicht direkt mit
olaf scholz auch am telefon besprechen
könnte wozu er dann friedrich merz quasi
als boten braucht
nein sie war es nochmal ich mache doch
meine reise nicht unter dem aspekt was
kann ich an botschaft mit nach hause
bringen und was gar nicht der
bundesregierung sagen das ist da
deutlich meine aufgabe meine aufgabe ist
mir ein persönliches bild zu machen von
der lage auch ein persönliches bild in
den gesprächen mit den repräsentanten
dieses landes und das habe ich heute
getan ich bin ja auch nicht alleine hier
ich habe meinen bundestagskollegen recht
diese wird damit dabei gehabt und wir
haben diese gespräche hier sehr intensiv
geführt und eines kann ich ganz gewiss
sagen die persönlichen gespräche sind
durch nichts zu ersetzen durch kein
telefon durch keine video kollegen und
auch die dankbarkeit mal entgegen zu
nehmen für das was wir auch in der
letzten woche im deutschen bundestag auf
unsere initiative hin beschlossen haben
das ist schon eine bestätigung dessen
dass wir da nicht ganz falsch gelegen
haben dass wir dann gemeinsam in bonn im
berliner bundestag besprochen haben also
das ist durch nichts zu ersetzen was
dann am persönlichen gesprächen die auch
stattfindet damals haben sich ihre
gesprächspartner in der ukraine denn
heute gewundert dass erst der deutsche
oppositionschef kommt und dann erst
möglicherweise der deutsche
regierungschef
ja das kann man so sagen also ich habe
hier auch im übrigen einen
medienaufgebot gefunden mit dem ich
weder gerechnet habe noch das ich
erwartet habe oder ausgelöst habe das
zeigt mir aber wie groß das bedürfnis
nach solchen persönlichen gesprächen ist
und deswegen kann ich es nur empfehlen
zu tun ich habe lange drauf gewartet die
bundesregierung hat es bis jetzt nicht
für richtig befunden das zu tun das ist
ihre entscheidung aber davon mache ich
dann meine entscheidung nicht abhängig
auch ein solches gespräch und eine
solche reise zu unternehmen
und ja die aufmerksamkeit war sehr groß
übrigens bis hin in die details der
abstimmung in der letzten woche die wir
im deutschen bundestag am 9 am
donnerstag hatten das wussten meine
gesprächspartner alle und zwar bis auf
das abstimmungsergebnis dass wir dann
dort auch gehabt haben was haben sie
denn dem ukrainischen präsidenten gesagt
dazu dass er den deutschen
bundespräsidenten ausgeladen hatte der
bundeskanzler sieht ja exakt das als
größtes hindernis für seine eigene reise
also wir haben darüber gesprochen aber
auch da bitte ich um verständnis dass
ich das jetzt hier im detail nicht
wiedergebe bevor ich das nicht dem
bundeskanzler gesagt habe ich will nur
vielleicht eines ganz grundsätzlich
sagen ich finde dass der sprachgebrauch
auf beiden seiten so sein sollte dass
wir uns die zusammenarbeit nicht unnötig
schwer machen wir müssen uns doch jetzt
hier nicht gegenseitig öffentlich
kritisieren sondern hier geht es um ein
land im krieg ein land das angegriffen
worden ist und den wir nach allen
kräften die wir haben helfen wollen und
das muss das gemeinsame ziel sein und
das sollte auch jenseits aller rhetorik
das ziel sein an denen wir unabhängig
davon welche rolle wir einnehmen ob
regierung oder opposition finden an dem
ziel müssen wir gemeinsam arbeiten jetzt
ist die konstellation aber doch schon
ein bisschen ungewöhnlich auch
verglichen mit anderen europäischen
ländern
wir sprechen gerade mit ihnen als
oppositionschef in kiew sie herr merz
haben natürlich nicht so sehr viel
mitbringen können an konkreten zusagen
als oppositionspolitiker verglichen mit
der regierung umgekehrt können sie das
haben sie auch schon getan natürlich
jetzt immer sagen seht her ich war da
der bundeskanzler nicht was hat diese
reise für ihren landtagswahlkampf in dem
sie ja auch gerade stecken gebracht
sie was ich glaube was wir beide müssen
uns mal ganz grundsätzlich darüber
verständigen ob oppositionsführer
überhaupt reisen dürfen oder nicht und
welchen sinn solche reisen haben ich
habe doch als oppositionsführer nicht
nur dann ein reiseanlass wenn ich etwas
mitzubringen habe ich nehme mir das
recht den anspruch jedes land dieser
welt aus eigenem anschauen heraus
anzusehen und reisen zu machen so wie
ich sie für notwendig und für richtig
halte auch um politische gespräche zu
führen und das geht doch nicht darum
dass sich jeweils in die eine oder die
andere richtung was mitbringe also da
kommt doch so ein unterton rein als
oppositionsführer nicht reisen dürfen
ich mache die reisen und zwar die die
ich für richtig halte er sie was und
heute nach kiew das war der
oppositionsführer im deutschen bundestag
friedrich merz ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch war aus termingründen vor
zweieinhalb stunden aufgezeichnet
seit jeher gehört zur agenda sämtlicher
despoten und diktatoren als erstes mal
die freiheit der presse abzuschaffen
damit niemand mehr unbequeme fragen
gestellt damit niemand mehr erfährt was
geschieht damit die vielstimmigkeit der
demokratie zum schweigen gebracht wird
demokratie da es in darkness ist der
wahlspruch der washington post und er
gilt nicht nur heute am welttag der
pressefreiheit
es sieht nicht gut aus auf der neuen
rangliste der organisation reporter ohne
grenzen deutschland verschlechtert sich
dort um drei plätze
griechenland um 38 steht jetzt auf rang
108 in der welt weit hinter bulgarien
und ungarn
und dann der krieg gegen die ukraine
einen krieg den die russische führung
auch gegen alle führt die über sie
kritisch berichten wollen und der arm
des kreml reicht bis nach berlin
stefanie dosch das russische haus in
berlin nur kulturinstitut angeblich von
hier sendete radio russkij oder auch
golos berliner dies archivaufnahmen
ein deutscher radiosender in russischer
sprache
seit sonntag sind die räume leer die
mikros abgebaut moskau gefiel wohl nicht
dass sie kritische bedingt krieg in der
ukraine berichteten also mussten sie
raus und sollten bis dahin schweigen man
hat uns gesagt es wäre schön wenn wir
bis zum auszug bis zum ersten mal
keine nachrichten und keine politischen
programme senden und nur musik spielen
ich sehe das wirklich auch als ein
eingriff in die pressefreiheit und zwar
ganz eindeutig wir fragen schriftlich
beim russischen haus nach sie antworten
nicht doch auf dem account der
russischen häuser bei telegramm etwas
das wirkt wie propaganda die haltung
klar
zitat
es gibt nazismus in der ukraine russland
beschützt diejenigen die seit acht
jahren genozid seitens der regierung in
kiew erleiden müssen
krieg um worte und bilder selten ist die
arbeit von journalistinnen und
journalisten so bedeutend wie in
militärischen konflikten und auch so
gefährlich
mindestens sieben starben in der ukraine
bereits
dieter krieg zeigt einmal mehr wie
wichtig pressefreiheit ist wie wichtig
unabhängige informationen sind und
gleichzeitig weil dieser konflikt ja die
ganze welt öffentlichkeit berührt und
mehr berührt als andere konflikte zeigt
es auch die bedeutung und auch die
gefährdung für pressefreiheit radio
golos berliner sendet weiter eine
medienhaus hat sie vorübergehend
aufgenommen zudem geben sie nun ihm eine
stimme andreas koch moderierte beim
unabhängigen radiosender echo moskau mit
beginn des krieges wurde dieser verboten
er flog meinungsfreiheit passt nicht in
putins krieg
vorher war es so dass wenn putin
beschuldigt wurde dass er die
meinungsfreiheit in russland zerstört
dann konnte er bequem sagen warum haben
wir die meinungsfreiheit zu stören wir
haben doch den radiosender echo moskau
den unabhängigen fernsehsender dort und
die zeitung nowaja gaseta
nun in kriegszeiten sind die dinge sehr
viel strikter und er kann es sich nicht
mehr leisten die geringste
meinungsfreiheit zuzulassen
zu berichten die zwei nun gemeinsam aus
berlin auf russisch kritisch über den
krieg in der ukraine putin kann das
nicht verhindern
russland steht bei reporter ohne grenzen
auf rang 155 von 180 im eigenen land
habe russland nach dem überfall auf die
ukraine die pressefreiheit de facto
abgeschafft
auf die spur des russischen präsidenten
seiner versteckten willen und reichtümer
hat sich einer gemacht der dafür bitter
bezahlen musste der den tod knapp
entgangen ist und jetzt in einem
straflager sitzt solange wladimir putin
an der macht ist dürfte alexej nawalny
kein freier mann mehr werden und
gleichzeitig hat auch navalny macht und
einfluss das zeigt ein bemerkenswerter
film der kein neutrales porträt von
navalny geworden ist sondern eine
chronik der dramatischen monate in
dessen leben ein politthriller aus der
realität unserer zeit den sich kein
autor so hätte ausdenken können barbara
lueg berichtet
nach deutschland zu kommen war nicht
meine absicht ich bin hier gelandet weil
man versucht hat mich umzubringen
alles beginnt mit diesem giftanschlag
dabei ließ schreie seine frau julia die
um sein leben kämpft
und schließlich nach venice genesung in
einem kleinen dorf im schwarzwald hier
trifft regisseur daniel joha mit seiner
kamera auf den großen putin-kritiker
schrittweise annäherung bis er uns in
sein leben gelassen hat bis er uns hat
filmen lassen das vertrauen hat sich so
ganz langsam aufgebaut
magst du mich
wochenlang begleitet der regisseur hier
in geheimer mission nicht nur den
regimekritiker navalny sondern auch den
menschen seine frau seine kinder
es sind intime einblicke szenen eine
offenheit die so noch nie zu sehen war
wie etwa die sorgen und gedanken seiner
tochter daria
[Musik]
in irgendeinem krankenhaus landet das
war so real wie in einem gremium
das beschauliche dorf im schwarzwald
entpuppt sich während der dreharbeiten
dann auch schon bald als kulisse eines
echten aufklärungs krimis navalny und
sein team machen das killerkommando das
ihn vergiftet haben soll ausfindig unter
falschen namen telefoniert er mit ihnen
vor laufender kamera es ist die
spektakulärste szene im film
warum ging die sache mittlerweile nie so
daneben
die arzt am boden hatten sofort
gehandelt und in irgendeinen gegen
mittel verabreicht wäre er nur ein
bisschen länger geflogen wäre wohl alles
anders ausgegangen
[Musik]
er hat die ganze geschichte
ausgeplaudert unglaublich
das war ein moment der so grundlegend so
schockierend so weltumspannend war ich
spreche kein wort russisch aber es war
völlig klar was da gerade im raum
passierte
wo hinterfragt den brillanten
medienstrategie navalny der seine
geschichten am liebsten selbst erzählt
kaum doch woraus große leistung ist die
unmittelbare nähe der zu ihm und seiner
familie fand zurück in moskau wird
navalny umgehend verhaftet im film
hinterlässt er zuvor eine botschaft
meine botschaft
vorbei für den fall dass sich umgebracht
werde ist sehr einfach gebt nicht auf
worte die navalny seinen landsleuten zu
ruft aber nun im straflager wohl auch
sich selbst
navalny der film eröffnet morgen das
münchner dok fest und läuft dann ab
donnerstag im kino und hier bei uns
heute hat hanna an diesem dritten
weitere wichtige nachricht auf schloss
meseberg ist heute die bundesregierung
zu einer zweitägigen klausurtagung
zusammengekommen
bestimmendes thema war auch hier der
krieg in der ukraine und seine konkreten
folgen für deutschland zum beispiel in
der sicherheits aber auch in der
wirtschaftspolitik
hier gebe es laut wirtschaftsminister
harbeck große herausforderungen aber
auch antworten wir werden diese zeit
überstehen wir haben die finanziellen
mittel wir haben die politischen
konzepte wir bauen die energieversorgung
um
nach nur kurzer amtszeit ist csu
generalsekretär stephan mayer heute
überraschend zurückgetreten in einer
erklärung nannte er gesundheitliche
gründe allerdings ging er darin auch auf
den gerade erst bekannt gewordenen
vorwurf ein dass er einen journalisten
bedroht haben soll in einem gespräch mit
einem reporter der bunten habe er zitat
möglicherweise eine wortwahl verwendet
die er rückblickend nicht für angemessen
betrachten würde erklärte meyer der 48
jährige war erst ende februar zum
generalsekretär gekürt worden und sollte
eigentlich den landtagswahlkampf im
kommenden jahr manager
die berliner staatsanwaltschaft hat
ermittlungen gegen ex verkehrsminister
scheuer aufgenommen die im zusammenhang
mit der gescheiterten pkw-maut stehen
konkret geht es um eine mögliche
falschaussage vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
neuer wehrt sich gegen die vorwürfe und
sagte er habe wahrheitsgemäß ausgesagt
die pkw maut war ein prestigeprojekt der
csu das 2009 10 vom europäischen
gerichtshof gekippt wurde trotz der noch
ausstehenden gerichtsentscheidungen
hatte scheuer allerdings bereits
verträge mit den vorgesehenen
betreiberfirmen geschlossen diese
verlangen nun vom bund 560 millionen
euro schadensersatz an
den weißen marmor stufen des imposanten
gebäudes mit der ebenso imposanten
adresse number one first street
washington dc protestieren sie heute die
einen und die anderen
der grund ist das was aus dem tempel des
rechts dort heraus gedrungen ist ein
leck das es in sich hat aus dem kleinen
eigentlich sehr verschwiegenen zirkel
der obersten richter der usa
da ist jetzt ein entwurf für einen
urteil an die öffentlichkeit gelangt
dass in amerika eine heftige debatte neu
entfacht das recht auf abtreibung ist in
gefahr es sieht so aus als ob die
obersten richter abrücken wollen von
rovers estate diese entscheidung ist
fast fünf jahrzehnte alt und sie spaltet
die usa wie kaum eine andere bis heute
relative
sie sind die vorboten einer unruhigen
zeit in amerika ihre überzeugungen
treiben sie auf die straße bringen sie
gegeneinander auf
sobald das alte urteil abgeschafft ist
müssen wir in den bundesstaaten
sicherstellen dass die gesetze gegen
abtreibung also für das leben
verabschieden
niemals zuvor wurde eine urteilsentwurf
öffentlich selten war eine entscheidung
so scharf formuliert von richter alito
bekannt für seine extreme wortwahl das
urteil von 1973 sei von beginn an
ungeheuerlich falsch gewesen die
begründung außerordentlich schwach die
bundesregelung durch keine
verfassungsrechtliche vorschrift gedeckt
ein beispiel für die ausübung neuer
juristischer macht deshalb sei es nun
zeit die verfassung zu beachten und die
abtreibungsfrage den gewählten
vertretern des volkes zurückzugeben
fünf konservative richter 3 von trump
nominierte wollen die bundesregelung
kippen so ergab eine probeabstimmung
richter alytus scharfe töne hatten schon
in der nacht volk
demonstranten beider seiten gerieten
aneinander vor dem obersten gerichtshof
wenn das urteil so kommt wird es das
land weiter spalten rund 60 prozent der
bevölkerung sind für eine liberale
regelung
alles für das wir gekämpft haben landet
im müll das ist lächerlich wir haben so
viel erreicht jetzt wird die zeit
zurückgedreht
das werden sie amerika nicht antun wir
sind mehr leute als sie wir werden
kämpfen
es droht ein kulturkampf im land etwa
die hälfte der bundesstaaten hat gesetze
parat nach denen ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch fast komplett
unmöglichkeit in oklahoma beispielsweise
wäre er dann ab der sechsten woche
strafbar also bevor viele frauen
bemerken dass sie schwanger sind
kliniken wie diese würden schließen
frauen in notsituationen müssten in
andere bundesstaaten reisen viele ärmere
hätten gar nicht die mittel dafür auch
unter republikanern gibt es kritik
wenn das urteil in die richtung des
entwurfs geht dann erschüttert dass mein
vertrauen in das gericht
präsident biden hält es für ein
grundsatzurteil dann könnten staaten
auch verhütung verbieten
gleichgeschlechtliche beziehungen
bestrafen und vieles mehr
es sind so viele fundamentale rechte
davon betroffen und ich bin nicht bereit
diese den launen der öffentlichkeit auf
lokaler ebene zu überlassen
es ist war ja in amerika beide seiten
werden alles tun um die wähler im land
in ihr lager zu ziehen
das thema aber trotz weiter beschäftigen
jetzt aber erstmal zurück nach
deutschland und normal hanna seit wochen
wird diskutiert was ein gas embargo oder
ein gas lieferstopp russlands für
deutschland bedeuten würde jetzt hat die
bundesnetzagentur eine umfrage gestartet
um das was wäre wenn zumindest etwas zu
klären und zwar valerie haller unter
unternehmen die besonders viel gas
verbrauchen worum geht es dabei genau ja
es geht darum einen überblick zu
bekommen über den gasbedarf einzelner
branchen und unternehmen um die
auswirkungen eines russischen
lieferstopps einfach besser einschätzen
zu können da gehen die meinungen weit
auseinander
fest steht schon mal deutschland hat
eine sehr gas intensive industrie manche
sparten sind besonders abhängig davon
wie zum beispiel die chemiebranche die
viele produkte herstellt die andere
industriezweige wiederum für ihre
produktion brauchen also wenn gas fehlt
hat das weitreichende folgen die
bundesnetzagentur fragt nun bei den 2500
größten gas verbrauchern daten ab um zu
wissen wer im notfall wie viel gas
braucht aktuell gibt es laut netzagentur
genug gas selbst im falle eines akuten
stopps die speicher sind zu 35 prozent
und damit für die jahreszeit ganz gut
gefüllt tendenz steigend nur im winter
würde es eng werden ohne russisches gas
doch selbst dann muss niemand frieren
haushalte werden per gesetz immer zuerst
versorgt gleichzeitig sollen andere gas
quellen erschlossen werden noch dieses
jahr sollen laut wirtschaftsminister
habe zwei schwimmende lng terminals in
betrieb genommen werden so könnte gas
über die deutschen häfen ins europäische
gasnetz eingespeist werden das könnte
wenn auch ein kleiner aber ein weiterer
schritt in richtung unabhängigkeit von
russischem gas werden in den kommenden
jahren sind dann auch stationäre thermen
geplant danke valerie nach frankfurt
die lage auf dem deutschen arbeitsmarkt
hat sich im april weiter verbessert und
das trotz des russischen angriffskriegs
in der ukraine
wie die bundesagentur für arbeit in
nürnberg mitteilte waren im april rund
zwei millionen
309.000 menschen arbeitslos 53.000
weniger als im märz die quote sank damit
leicht auf 5 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahr waren es 462 1000 weniger
arbeitslose die erholung sei auf die
frühjahrsbelebung und die lockerungen
der korona maßnahmen zurückzuführen
nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
gho ist mehr als die hälfte der
erwachsenen in europa übergewichtig
dabei sei der anteil bei den männern mit
63 prozent höher als bei den frauen mit
54 prozent
übergewicht und fettleibigkeit hätten
epidemische ausmaße erreicht erklärte
die whu 13 prozent aller todesfälle in
der region seien darauf zurückzuführen
weil das risiko für viele krankheiten
wie krebs oder herz
kreislauferkrankungen erhöht ist
das war unsere welt an diesem dienstag
gleich nach uns jetzt 37 grad hetze hass
gewalt wie auch das zum alltag von
politikern wurde und dann legen wir
ihnen natürlich für 22 uhr 45 den
kollegen markus lanz ans herz sehr
spannende runde unter anderem mit dem
spd-generalsekretär kevin kühnert 22 uhr
45 markus lanz und
gegen mitternacht gibt's dann unser
heute-journal update mit nasa spannendes
zdf programm von uns allen hier ein
angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das ist der
satelliten film von heute und er zeigt
uns etliche
wolkenfelder hier in der mitte und auch
nach südost nennen aber im tagesverlauf
haben sich dann schauer und gewitter
entwickeln das sind hier diese kleinen
weißen punkte das sind quellwolken und
teilweise gewitter die sich teilweise
auch nur sehr langsam bewegt haben
deswegen gab es durchaus ordentlich
regen nach norden war es dann eher
trocken diese wolken hier das sind keine
gewitter diesen tarlós wir schauen in
die nacht und da gibt es noch letzte
schauer im südwesten und auch in den
alpen es lässt nach ansonsten klart es
auf nach nordosten hin und im binnenland
richtung ostsee wird es eisig minus 1
grad ansonsten null grad richtung
norddeutsche tiefebene und 9 grad plus
am im rhein-main-gebiet ja und morgen da
an im tagesverlauf erst einmal so
anscheinend auch im süden und dann
brodelt es erneut wieder schauer und
gewitter und es kann durchaus bei
gewittern bis zu 20 liter auf den
quadratmeter innerhalb einer stunde
geben und das ganze dehnt sich aus bis
etwa zur mitte sonst aber wieder
trockenes wetter die höchsten
temperaturen liegen bei 11 bis 14 grad
richtung nordsee häufig vor allem in der
südhälfte bisher etwa 20 22 grad dann
richtung rhein main gebiet und die
nächsten tage am donnerstag noch einmal
ziemlich durchwachsen im süden 14 bis 20
grad und freitag deutlich ruhiger damit
ein schöner abend